and the winner is corvadis aida yasmilas
banich
european cinema lovers along with meps
chose the bosnian film as the winner of
the 2022 lux audience award citizens and
members each accounted for 50 of the
vote
all three shortlisted films draw from
historical events but their subjects are
extremely topical today as we know too
well about the disasters of an ongoing
war in ukraine and the plight of
displaced people forced to flee for
their safety
kovar decider recounts the events of the
massacre in srebrenica where ida a
school teacher and un translator lives
with her family while supposedly under
un protection more than 8 000 bosnian
muslim civilians were murdered by
serbian forces
this film shows what are the
consequences of war uh mothers of
reverence are still searching for more
than one thousand bodies of their sons
it shows how
war genocide leaves consequences 30
years after
when general ratko mladic leads his
serbian troops into the city ida is
recruited to help communication between
evacuees and the un
she becomes the witness of a failing
peacekeeping mission
colonel carmens
they are killing people outside
i
believe if we don't stop the war in
ukraine we will have devastated europe
in a few years so i really would like
people to see the film and find a way to
stop it but celebrities have happened
because nobody stopped it
cuovardis ida is a dilemma-filled
thriller chronicling the horrors of 1995
and the failure of international
institutions
[Music]
you